hey you guys it's haunting monday
yay
these are the shows these are fun
[Laughter]
he's almost like tom was saying last
night he's like it's almost kind of like
a little treat like getting to watch a
haunting episode like on sunday nights
yeah like we haven't do we have a
cocktail and
watching haunting and then try to
analyze the case and i and i sit here
writing down and please forgive me i did
not have time to
type up my notes so i have like this is
my notebook here and because i just
wrote them in the notebook like while i
was in the other room like yeah writing
a nose down like old school by hand like
in nothing
transcripts or any of this to this one
this one's gonna a little tough to
figure out because there's
not much evidence
well and the thing about it too is that
it was one of those ones this is a
really good episode actually
and i had forgotten uh about this one
because i forgot that's what this one
was called but um
this is one where the people
didn't want to appear so they're in
shadow and i'm assuming then that they
didn't use their real names like they
named them
but i'm like that'd be pretty dumb if
they used their real name and then like
just said it sat in the [ __ ] yeah so
when that happens you can't find
anything you can't really find out what
the case is from their point of view you
got to go you got to go with whatever
haunting says whatever the haunting
series says yeah so you didn't actually
find the
the raw case no some anywhere okay
so we so we don't behind a firewall
well me i mean i unless somebody has
like had more time to like do sleep more
sleuthing than me but i didn't really
have a lot of time so yeah and usually
you know
we we know the haunting series pretty
well
uh they pad that case out all right they
uh they fill that case out quite quite a
bit
and sometimes they'll leave whole story
lines out
they'll leave whole people out sometimes
um
so
even though this is a great episode
i wouldn't take it at face value
i wouldn't take that i would really yeah
this one um
well it seems like a lot of the stuff
that happens is pretty
let's call it like definitive
in the sense that they're pretty sure
that this a ghost and everything was
like supposedly crystal clear like all
of the evidence that they had but of
course they didn't show any of them
like really like evps they said they had
them they didn't show
yeah so
i don't know so i'm skeptical photos of
ghostly babies they showed a mock-up but
they didn't show the actual photo i kind
of watched that sounds like that sounds
like some weird like indie band album
album name
photos of ghostly babies
i kind of want to write a story called
that now i don't know i just like i just
like the cadence of that phrase yeah
and uh
the guy investigating seems sincere but
you gotta take everything at his word
and uh
like i said we we know by experience of
dealing with the haunting
when you actually look deeper into it
the haunting series leaves a lot out
of what actually happened or what was
reported to happen
so
you can you know so we don't really know
and uh what was described
really not all that impressive mostly
just footsteps i think the only thing
that actually moved is somebody threw a
[ __ ] a candle
it wasn't a candle it was like it was a
bottle or a bottle that's what it was it
goes through a bottle
it hurt footsteps this was much more
like a haunting haunting like actual
ghosts rather than like poltergeist
activity and they're doing [ __ ] like
seances and [ __ ] using little [ __ ]
things that point things
to uh
and what is it [ __ ] using ouija
boards to try to get messages from
beyond a boy that really [ __ ] you up
as soon as they start
talking to the from beyond
because you're going to get all kinds of
stories
and are they ever going to prove the
stories no
no probably not no
it's [ __ ] they're going to say yeah we
dig here we'll find it you know that
kind of [ __ ] and then they well we we
couldn't dig there you know just it's
gonna be [ __ ] like that
um
whenever you're dealing with ouija
boards and dowsing and
there's a there's a [ __ ]
there's always a chance of a human hand
in there
adding to the case
you know
so like i said
you can only take it at face value you
know you could always only take it the
hauntings word for it
it's a tall tale but it's a good episode
it is a good episode yeah i don't know
if i believe it but uh it's a good
episode anyway like just for like it
would make you know it's good for like a
fictional story zack says uh there are
only ever two reasons to appear in
shadow on tv you're in danger or are
more full of [ __ ] than a competitive
eater
samantha b said what's the case what
town and state they said that it was in
montreal in 1996.
yeah the case is um
darkness darkness follows darkness
follows it was a good one about the
ghosts
of an abortionist who uh killed some
girl during a botched abortion and
supposedly buried her underneath the
floor well don't give it all away well
we'll get to it
well that's right she's a woman they
like to tell it as they go man i want to
tell you the whole story first and then
go back and tell you the story we're
going to give you a sneak yes yeah i
don't get that like i said you're
spoiling the end that's not spoiler
you're spoiling the ending they've all
seen this one it's like well if you
already told me the ending then why do i
need to stick around and listen to you
because we're gonna go back to detail
we're gonna pick through it okay
he's gonna tell you that right well you
see the thing is is men when they tell a
story they're to tell you they're going
to say the end first and wait but hold
on how'd that happen and then you're
going to hear how it happened
that's just something the guys do every
guy in here will tell you you can't keep
a guy's attention you just start at the
beginning it's like i don't want to hear
the jit because they don't wait to the
end not wait till the end of that
because they all have a dd yeah no i
don't want to wait today well like i
said you spoiled it
that's 20 minutes from now and it's the
end price sucks so you got to get them
to end first and go that's a good ending
what had to happen that's how
that's
every dude i ever [ __ ] do is like
that zack says also as we speak i'm
pirating a copy of that old michael
douglas kathleen turner movie war of the
roses i actually really really like that
movie i would like to re-watch it at
some point i think i saw that in the
theater actually i don't remember it oh
it's good it's like a like a dark comedy
about uh
there are a couple and they're getting
divorced and uh yeah it's it's super
hilarious i remember it being really
funny but i haven't seen it for a really
long time so yeah so this case this was
uh one of those
great classic season one episodes i
think it was episode six most of the
stuff that i saw said season one episode
six one one thing i saw said episode
five but whatever the [ __ ] and cause
sometimes it's confusing even though
like the wikipedia page because
wikipedia has like a list of all the
episodes like sometimes i don't know if
it was because they shot one and then
they didn't show it till later because
sometimes the numbering is kind of like
messed up but i think this one is
uh episode six like of season one and it
was like we had um it was like the
second one on the disc right because we
had like the couple
discs whatever but yeah like most of the
most of the episodes that you guys
requested were
season one i feel like because i was
pulling all of them out last night and
looking at like all the ones on the list
and almost all of them were season one
i've been wanting to do this one because
this is one of the first ones that
somebody requested
when i asked for episodes so
and i didn't remember which one this was
but that's true of all of them because
they have such generic names
so like i said i don't know
these are not these people's names uh
obviously they gave them uh pseudonyms
and they just appeared in shadow so this
apparently happened like i said in
montreal
in
1996.
now at the very beginning you have this
woman uh they're calling her kelly
fontaine
and she has a daughter that they're
calling hayley i don't remember how old
the daughter was she doesn't factor into
it like all that much played by the same
actress that did the girl from the show
we just did last at last no that no the
daughter wasn't that well before no but
i was the same one no it's the same
getting mad at me no because i'm trying
to explain to you
it's the same actress as the one we did
before but it's but she's not playing
the daughter she's playing the ghost oh
it's the ghost she's the dead girl okay
she's not like the main family's
daughter that was like that was like a
little little girl okay well there was
one girl that was in this one that's
about 20.
she wasn't a ghost though
a girl yeah that was a different that
was a different yeah that looked like
that same actress
the actress that was in the one
that we did the other day that played
the teenage daughter getting pulled
through the thing yeah yeah she is in
this one but she's not playing the main
family's daughter that's what i'm trying
to tell you she was playing the ghost
she's a ghost really yeah she's dead did
you miss that whole angle or i thought
she was the daughter no it looked like
the same girl no that it is the same
girl yeah but she's just wearing she's
just wearing bell bottoms and [ __ ]
jeans and [ __ ] she was a ghost she was a
ghost we'll get into that okay the
family like the woman kelly fontaine
has a daughter already but that daughter
is like six okay you know what i mean
they don't have another kid like she
gets pregnant and she has another kid
later but like the that woman is in it
that girl is in it but she plays like a
ghost that they contact like later on
she's not their daughter okay you know
what i'm saying
yeah she's someone's daughter but not
theirs okay i thought she showed does
that make any sense i thought she showed
up with the family that's just how i
remembered it no no she's like no she's
the ghost good so uh so kelly has i
guess she's like a single mom so she has
this daughter i think the daughter's
name is haley or at least that's what's
called they're calling her on the show
let me fold this up because it's kind of
like a pain in the ass but um yeah so
at the first
kind of thing they show uh the mom and
the daughter and they're like walking
down the street and she said oh this one
thing that we used to do all the time
is we would walk around all these
neighborhoods around where we lived and
we would fantasize about
like pick out our favorite houses uh you
know what i mean like ooh that one's so
pretty and blah blah so they said the
weird thing about this was that one
house that they would pass all the time
was like this really big like kind of
spooky looking house and that was her
and her daughter's favorite and they
were always walking past it and being
like oh how cool it would be to like
live in there and stuff like that
so then kelly is dating this dude named
al
and a little while later i guess al
surprises them and says hey i bought us
a house we're all going to move in
together because they hadn't moved they
hadn't lived together prior to this yeah
and it turns out that it was the same
exact house
that
her and her daughter like always walked
by and were like yeah that's the coolest
house ever so he's like oh i didn't even
know and i bought you guys that house
like we're all gonna live there now and
you know they want to like start another
family and blah blah blah
so they go to this big house i don't
know what the real house looked like but
like i said but it was like kind of a
big uh big huge one like an old one
and uh so the thing about it is that
they move in and they get it repainted
and everything like that and then
they're just like well uh kelly and al i
guess want to have a baby like have
another kid because i think the daughter
haley is just kelly's because i don't
think they've been dating that long it
seems like but i don't know
so pretty much the first thing that
happens like before they even it seemed
like before they even really moved in
they said before they moved in they had
painters come in and like fix everything
up and stuff
so they were in there like looking at
all the paint stuff and then like they
heard footsteps
he said it sounded like somebody walking
down the stairs like very very clearly
like somebody walking downstairs
so they go over there and obviously
there's nobody there so they're just
like huh that's really weird um that
just must be one of those house settling
kind of situations you know how that
happens that sounds exactly like
somebody walking to like an invisible
person walking down the stairs but i
mean at least according to the show
that's what it sounded like but so they
just kind of like write it off like yeah
whatever it's just an old house and we
have to get used to it yadda yadda
so then they move in
now a few weeks later
kelly is home by herself
and her doctor calls and she discovers
that you know hey she's pregnant and
she's like super excited about it al
super excited blah blah blah
now
while she's on the phone with the doctor
right after she gets off the phone with
the doctor
she hears footsteps and she said that
the footsteps again sounded like they
were in the exact same room as her like
she was in the front room like folding
laundry or some [ __ ] and
she said it sounded like somebody kind
of like walked into the room like and
was in the same room with her but
obviously she didn't see anybody
so she was just kind of like okay that's
pretty creepy but then kind of like
writes it off and pretends nothing
happened right
so later that night like al comes home
and she's like oh i'm pregnant and he's
like oh yay and then she's like
um oh and also i heard some like
footsteps in the house so i think the
ship might be haunted or something
and he's like oh it's probably just the
house settling yada yada but then
they both hear it like at the same time
what is very very clearly
uh footsteps
now here's what's interesting about this
episode
normally what happens in these episodes
of haunting as you guys are probably
familiar with
it's like there'll be a couple of like
weird little things that happen like oh
a door will be left open or somebody
will hear some weird noises or something
like that and then you'll just keep
saying like you know you'll keep coming
up for some like reason
like what it is you know what i mean
like some explanation
in this one pretty much the minute that
they both hear the footsteps
al's like hey i have this friend that's
a paranormal investigator let's call him
and see what the [ __ ] going on and i
was like wow that escalated quickly i
mean all is literally all they've heard
is footsteps at this point so
well now that that kind of makes sense
in terms of
i remember when the math mountain thing
went went on you know we were we were in
denial
for a little while but you know after a
while you couldn't deny it
so i can see that but
and and the disturbances aren't real
they're just auditory it sounds like
footsteps maybe you're going like sounds
like footsteps but it can't be
you're like it's not it can't sound like
it came into the room but it can't be
must have didn't happen you know down
the basement or
it's an echo you know
it's happening over there but it sounds
like it's happening there so i can kind
of see that part
well that's well that's the thing but
what i'm saying is that you know they
hear the footsteps and then the guy is
just kind of like oh maybe it was
somebody outside that was walking around
but then like literally the third time
they hear it and actually it's only the
second time he's heard it because he
didn't hear it like first when uh his
girlfriend was just at home by herself
but literally the second time he hears
footsteps he's like okay time to call
the paranormal investigators and i'm
like usually the dude like
doesn't even want to like know about it
but he might have been cool and maybe it
probably didn't happen exactly what they
showed that's yeah that's what i'm
saying but you know well that's what i'm
saying they're taking a look i was just
saying it was in a way it was like kind
of refreshing because i do kind of get
pissed off by the whole formula of you
know almost like i feel like 85 percent
of the episodes are
you know the women and children are
always at home
like alone all the time because for
whatever reason like the the wife hardly
ever works
and the dude always like works either
long hours or works overnight so they're
always like at home like when it's
creepy and dark outside
and
also they'll start seeing [ __ ] for a
really long time and it takes it has to
escalate like a lot before like the dude
will see it and he always gets like
really cranky like every time they bring
it up so i feel like 85 of the episodes
are like that so it was all it was kind
of nice when you see one where the dude
is like right away
yeah there's some paranormal [ __ ] going
on let's do something about that yeah
what it probably was is probably more
along the lines of [ __ ] he saw some
[ __ ] heard some [ __ ] with her to go man
that was this [ __ ] creepy he says
yeah
my friend know all knows all about this
let's call it it's probably more that's
what i'm saying because i mean to be
honest with you
i don't know it would take i'm not
really sure how much it would take for
me to be like calling the paranormal
investigators you know it would have to
be a lot probably
and yeah well i don't know even if i
thought it was paranormal i'd be like
well well you seen it you didn't call
one well no that's what i mean yeah um
yeah because then you're gonna got a
third party in your house like what the
hell are they gonna do what's he gonna
do
just like wave some sage around i can do
that yeah you're gonna drop oil around
the outside yeah
[ __ ] um no it's
a lot of times it's kind of common you
know if you research these cases that
the dude goes into denial he doesn't
want to [ __ ] hear it
and then you know if you press them
they're like if you pay attention they
say [ __ ] like or they believe or they
are thinking to themselves if you pay
attention to it it gets stronger if you
ignore it it'll go away so they try to
go into denial
yeah
which
that's that's a typical male [ __ ]
defensive mechanism because he can't
[ __ ]
fight it with his fists
you know he's like well i'm out of
options
i can't i can't punch it so i'm just
going to pretend it's stuff and in the
case in the cases of these
in the cases out of this series most of
these people are [ __ ] strapped for
cash
so it's not like you can pick up a move
you know
yeah that's the shitty so he's trapped
there so you can't fight it you can't
move so you just ah it's not there oh
you're crazy don't pay any attention to
it
pay attention to get stronger that kind
of stuff yeah yeah
but in this one and i think maybe like
in light of what happens like later on
in the episode where the dude gets like
super super into it yeah maybe he was
just really interested in the paranormal
it was like ooh neat you know what i
mean because he heard it he's like maybe
it's a ghost and he's like all excited i
don't know but like that seemed like
he's more open too he yeah he seemed
like he was a lot more open like uh just
hearing footsteps and he's like yeah
we're gonna call somebody and see like
what they say about it so he had a
friend that would paranormal i wasn't
there i didn't hear the footsteps but
they convinced him so
yeah so they must have really been yeah
footsteps according to the story may
have not been like this might this might
be completely fictional from start to
finish i'm not really not sure there's
no way of knowing like i said now they
now this people that were on there that
was like the the paranormal investigator
guy
um or one of the or the the medium or
whatever guy that they brought in whose
name what was his name richard paul
masano masano was that his name he was
on there like he wasn't in shadow or
anything like that so maybe if you look
back through his [ __ ] maybe you can like
find probably find out more about who
who these people are but
unless he doesn't want to unless they
don't want anybody knowing about it
which i kind of figure they didn't but
he turned up on there so but the people
themselves didn't
so um
so richard the guy they call the
paranormal investigator
his idea he comes there and he says okay
what i think you should do is every time
you leave the house
you turn on a tape recorder because so
far it's just been like auditory stuff
like they've been hearing footsteps and
[ __ ] like that
so basically what happens is that uh
richard also says i think maybe that
this spirit or whatever is particularly
attracted to kelly because more stuff
happens i'm assuming when just she's at
home
so next day kelly goes out the house
and leaves a tape recorder running like
she sits it on the staircase or
something like that and she said i very
deliberately like went out the door and
said okay i'm leaving now and like
slammed the door
so and nobody else was in the house
everybody like i was at work and the
kids were the kid was at school and all
that other kind of [ __ ] so she's like so
i knew that anything that happened like
after that was not me and wasn't anybody
else so it had to be like paranormal
so she leaves it now they all come back
that night and they listen to the tape
and
this is what i mean when this is like
because you know how a lot of times
it'll be like oh it was just something
that you could still maybe write it off
as maybe something natural or you were
mishearing it or something this one
seemed like some real like horror movie
[ __ ] because they play it back and they
said they heard footsteps then they
heard like a jingling kind of sound like
somebody walking with like a charm
bracelet on they said that's what it
sounded like
and
like a weird voice they said look is a
really creepy voice that was clearly not
human i don't think at first that they
could tell what it was saying
but uh kelly said that it was uh quote
unquote awful
and also said that there was kind of
like sighing
uh that they thought sounded like uh i
think the word he used was abandonment
like it sounded like somebody going oh
like they're leaving or something like
that like it sounded like that um i
couldn't tell if it was like multiple
voices maybe but i couldn't really tell
like what the voices were
now uh
al or richard i can't remember who
one of the dudes
he said that he had met i guess it was
al like prior to him buying the house
he said that he had met the former
tenants of the house i don't think they
bought this house i think they were just
renting it because there was a whole
thing later like with the owner of the
house i'm assuming they were just
renting
so he said oh i knew the previous
tenants and the voice on that tape
sounds like the daughter of the woman
that used to live here that's what he
said he said it sounded like her teenage
daughter that's who was played by yeah
see now i remember what it was that was
that was the that was the the bar fly
chick's daughter
yeah yeah that's right yeah
so he's like yeah that voice sounds just
like her
and he's like this is what happened with
them like if she was a single mom like
uh she had this 15 year old daughter and
i wrote down mom was a ho
well because it was just like well i was
writing while i was watching the show
and she didn't they didn't call her home
but they but i just said well that'll
that'll give me the
that'll give me the gist like in the
shortest i didn't remember i didn't
remember her as a ghost because she's
not shown as a ghost really she's shown
in a flashback right so that's how i was
going she wasn't a ghost she was just
regular yeah
she wasn't a ghost she was just regular
yeah i was remembered but i couldn't
quite
couldn't quite play stuff
that was so funny to me
because i know how they [ __ ] show
ghosts
well she did she did kind of do some
ghosty [ __ ] later like after she like
crosses over or whatever but yeah yeah
so uh so what happened there
apparently was that so they showed like
a flashback
and the mom like i said was a hoe that
was just like leave the 15 year old
daughter and she was like a drug addict
or drunk or something like that and she
was like going around bar to go she's
going out to the bar like picking
picking up some help pay those bills
jumping on some d yeah like all around
town money for the yeah well hey she got
to pay the rent somehow oh yeah she's
trying to don't hate yeah so
that's all she got that's all she had to
sell i guess
i mean this is a pretty big house i
don't know how she can afford it but
anyway
anyway uh the mom was gonna get evicted
right uh so i don't know so one night
she goes out like you know bar hopping
or whatever and leaves the 15 daughter
15 year old daughter at home alone and
the 15 year old daughter is basically
like yeah i've had enough of this [ __ ]
and she takes a bunch of pills to kill
herself now
what apparently happened was that
she after she took all the pills like
she had a change of heart and she was
like oh maybe this killing myself thing
isn't like so cool after all and she
called 9-1-1 but they said by the time
that the ambulance got there it was
already too late so she had already died
so we're led to believe that this
teenage girl is one of the ghosts that's
haunting the house
so
subsequently they they pretty much start
turning tape recorders on like every
single time they leave
and they get all kind of voices
one that they got in particular they
said when of course they didn't show
they didn't like play the real ones on
the show because they hardly ever do but
they said there was this one really
weird time where there was nobody in the
house and they left the tape recorder on
and they said this girl's this teenage
girl's voice they said it sounded like
she was talking to somebody on the phone
like you could hear her end of the
conversation but not the other end of
the conversation i'm like so a ghost is
talking on the phone why does a ghost
need to talk on the phone she's in a
dream i guess so she's reliving a
picture is she talking to another ghost
or is she talking to her she's in
progress i want to know no she's talking
to her friend
she's in purgatory
basically
but yeah in kind of a dream-like state
out of body
[ __ ] in an in-between or at least a
part of her is something like that
i could imagine it
yeah so they said but it basically
sounded like one end of a phone call
except it was like a ghost voice which
would be really weird you know yeah uh
holy parish of doom said nearly every
supernatural themed movie uses the same
formula about the male boyfriend husband
et cetera character always written to be
the rational minded skeptic yeah i kind
of feel like 85 90 95 percent of cases i
don't think it's written that way it's
just that's the way the stories are told
because most people are the same well
i'm not talking i'm talking about like
horror movie like fictional horror
movies a lot of them are written like
that yeah there's not not much variation
you know you can only do so much in a
house
you gotta work and you know most people
are pretty much the same
zack says i can't punch it and it has no
holes i can put anything in what do i do
now
yeah pretty much
you can't fight a ghost
my boy tried
[Laughter]
from death from deltona
yeah sure this guy kind of tried to well
he kind of yelled at the ghost but you
know what i mean that didn't work out so
well
um so yeah jake says why do ghosts at
haunt houses always have to be creepy
why can't we have normal ghosts that
greet you when you come home and have
normal conversations see that's what i
now i've read a couple of books like
that
but you don't really see a lot of movies
like that it's like yeah why can't you
have a ghost that like cleans up your
[ __ ] while you're while you're gone like
washes your dishes and that'd be kind of
neat you guys my pulse guys folded up
towels and folded up hand towels and
left them out for you give you little
bars of soap
see that's helpful
but that's not that's not it that's how
it goes it's creepy well yeah it'd be
creepy but after a while like if they
were doing nice things for you all the
time you'd kind of get used to it
we were like this must be room service
doing this
there were no room service just kept
leaving that at the foot of the bed so
you know where you sit it's just weird
but i i've read a couple like i said
i've read a couple of books like that
where the ghost was like friendly yeah
for or at least seemed friendly like at
first was like doing stuff for the
people yeah you walk out of a room and
then to go like two steps and then go
back into the room and shut the door
behind you and on the back of that
doorknob to be a [ __ ] hand towel
folded up and you know you just grabbed
that doorknob to open it [ __ ] weird
you're like and you look at that thing
and you're going like wait that's from
the bathroom that would have had to go
come right through the damn
hallway i didn't see that passing me so
it just teleported in there
it was [ __ ] creepy man
i wish i had a ghost that would fold my
laundry that would be really cool well
it wasn't laundry just you know i know
but no i know i'm just saying that that
would be really cool yeah you couldn't
count on it
and like you know scrubbed out the tub
and all that yeah that'd be [ __ ]
awesome but
i want a ghost made so uh so yeah
so after all this so alan richard like i
said al
uh unlike many of the dudes on a
haunting show he's like super jazzed
about this and he's just like man i want
to find out what the [ __ ] is going on so
him and richard his paranormal
investigator friend
they set up like all these cameras and
[ __ ] like up in the upstairs hallway
so richard is over there and he brings
his wife over to hang out with kelly and
they're gonna play bridge downstairs
while while the men's are upstairs
investigating ghosts
and whatnot
now uh the wife i don't think they ever
named her actually the wife of richard
uh she goes to put her coat in the
closet or something like that and she
opens the closet and she said it was
like a freezing cold like blast of air
came back it was like freezing freezing
gold in there like a meat locker so
there was that
so then they're all like in the living
room and then they start hearing like
creaking footsteps and kind of like
voices upstairs like proper like a bunch
of people like talking
so uh richard and al like go up there
because they're like ooh maybe we've got
something on camera and like they hear
all these voices up there so they go up
there and richard said it kind of looked
like on the show like he got hit by
something like he was like one like went
against the wall
he said on the show like the interview
with the real guy he said it felt like
something ran through him
yeah that's what he said it sounded like
and it sort of like knocked him against
the wall
and then they listened to the audio tape
back and they said they heard and i
think this is the first time that they
actually heard a male voice because
prior to this it was usually like the
teenage girls voice they've been hearing
so he says like this time they hear an
angry male voice that says something
like i'm gonna get you or some [ __ ] like
that and it's i couldn't tell like
and i don't think think they specified
if the ghost was like talking to them or
if it was maybe talking to another ghost
because it was like some [ __ ] because
you know how a lot of episodes of
haunting too have like one thing where
well you have like all these kind of
nice cool ghosts in here but then you
have this one ghost who's a real dick
and he's like kind of like controlling
the other ghosts and like won't let them
leave and show like that this is a
situation like that let me say something
okay that whole something going through
you feeling we had that
at mammoth too me and red noticed it
sort of said to lois
usually like when you're in a hallway
and it'd be like three three you three
of you in the hallway and it would hit
one person then the middle one then the
last one because you feel it yeah
whatever it was it was weird
and
we try to analyze how it felt
you know like was it really cold you
know what i mean if we had a thermometer
there would it [ __ ] show it didn't
really feel like it it moved through you
kind of like a wind but there was no
wind
whatever it was it wasn't real
to sharply defined or delineated
where it was
that cold feeling and not you know it's
like whatever it was it was just like a
zone
now you know maybe about four or five
feet long and it was
kind of smeared and we gotta go through
you know what i'm talking about yeah it
wasn't like a sphere going through you
or anything or a round ball or a cube
going through you it was kind of like
something
like a comet
that'd be a good way to put it
you know what i mean it would get you
and then and then you could feel it
kind of like a weird tingling kind of a
cold sensation but you weren't really
sure if it was temperature if it was
fear or electric cool stuff and it would
kind of fade like like it had a tail on
it it went through you it's like that
yeah it's weird
you're like did you feel that yeah i
felt that you know like it went through
us yeah yeah
it's just weird
weird there's some kind of damn energy
ball
zack said i was at a graveyard during
the day one time and had a burst of air
rush up on my back true story
that was somebody farting man
[Laughter]
you farted maybe ghosts fart maybe it
was a ghost fart
yeah he just said maybe a good spartan
no because i mean you know we had it
happen it doesn't blow like a wind
you know what i mean like it
there's no wind or disturbance it's just
something with going through space it's
weird
maybe it's different for other people
maybe it's more than one phenomenon
people are reporting but the one that we
had in mammoth
was not wind per se it was something
moving through space
you could feel it
it was invisible and it was just going
through space it wasn't displacing
anything or pushing air out of the way
or anything
danny rowling said it would be sick if a
ghost could join you for a multiplayer
online session of halo 3.
yeah and it lifts your ass
well i would imagine rifle i mean i
would be really really disappointed if a
ghost couldn't whip your ass i mean you
know whips your ass with the shotgun
yeah
so uh so yeah so they hear this angry
male voice like richard gets you know
biffed against the wall or whatever then
they hear like a whole bunch of
footsteps again
and then the closet door
i guess is the same closet that was like
freezing cold inside it like opens by
itself and this is like downstairs so
like the the two women are down there
and at this point kelly and richard's
wife are like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and they're
like we're getting the [ __ ] out of here
so they all leave because they're scared
now they come back the next day and the
the ladies are just kind of like yeah
you guys go right ahead we're just gonna
stay out here in the driveway thank you
very much um so the men's go inside to
like make sure that everything is
copacetic
and they don't see anything weird at
first but then they go upstairs and on
the second floor they said all that was
unusual in there
was they found and i know everyone's
gonna laugh when i say this
was they found on the wooden floor like
a bunch of black
skid marks not those kind of skid marks
but the kind from
like shoes they said it looked like
somebody
wearing black shoes had like run around
like they were chasing somebody which i
which you even said that sounds like
kind of a reach yeah and i was like
ghosts don't wear shoes yeah well ghosts
don't wear shoes and how do you know
those weren't there before they didn't
mention
that they didn't mention you know
if they had inspected that floor before
they found those which i guess i
guarantee you they didn't disturbance
happens he goes in there and looks
around for something look skid marks and
[ __ ] yeah and like maybe you didn't even
notice it before and like that could
have been that's just a reach man ghosts
don't have [ __ ] shoes
yeah jake some [ __ ] running
around the house scuffing the floors
right i was just kind of like yeah i
could understand the
audi apparitions or maybe the sounds of
people running around and
so you picking up things like that maybe
that's what it was maybe falling over
and [ __ ] maybe maybe that's why he
jumped to that conclusion because they
said well it's like the sounds we heard
or just hypothetically sounded like some
like a man chasing someone around and so
then they were like oh look there's
evidence of it yeah like okay in mammoth
we'd find
spooky [ __ ] being moved
in one of the back bathrooms up on the
[ __ ] ceiling way up out of reach we
could none of us could reach it without
a ladder there was a we noticed a
[ __ ] greasy hand print up there
and it was also looks like somebody
wiped some hands on the damn curtains
but
there's no way of knowing whether the
ghost did that or somebody did that in
there long ago
you know what i mean
yeah that's what i'm saying it was
creepy looking but
i don't think the ghost did that i
called into the ghost you know blows or
whatever the poetry guys i don't think
it had anything to do with it it's just
the poultry guys was going on and we saw
that hand print and it creeped us out
but i don't think that was related to
the case i think it was there before
well yeah i mean when you're in an
environment like that where weird shits
happen and you're gonna notice stuff and
probably some of that stuff doesn't have
anything you didn't have to do it but
you know what i mean yeah i mean that
would be weird if like well just a lone
hand print up on this up on the ceiling
well yeah i'd be thinking about that too
like how the [ __ ] did that happen you
know what i mean you'd need a ladder to
get it well yeah somebody maybe did it
yeah maybe they were up there like
hanging some curtains or like changing a
light bulb or some [ __ ] like that and
we're like whoa you know what i mean and
they had like real [ __ ] dirty ass
greasy hands yeah
and they didn't think about it but
seeing it me and red are like man did it
touch the ceiling and i just because you
start leaping to conclusions you know
what i mean [ __ ] but we just kind of
blew that blew that off and because we
were like no maybe not maybe that was
already there we you know we were sound
enough of mine to go that may have been
already been there but it was creepy
yeah
i don't know why i just thought of this
but when you were talking about like
that uh handprint up on the ceiling
i was thinking about uh dan bell's show
another dirty room like where they go in
the hotel room and then a lot of times
they'll do like the ultraviolet light
and everything like that and you find
like all kinds of um pooch marks
interesting fluids all around yeah and
so i'm sitting there and probably
they're doing this too and i'm just
sitting there going
what went on in this room like where was
everyone standing what was happening
it's not just
it's not just the spooge mark sometimes
it's when they take actually when i
watch the other day i was like oh my god
i don't like sometimes i don't know why
i watch it because it just makes me want
to throw up like every time i watch it
but one of the mattresses
dude i don't know what the [ __ ] happened
on that mattress but
it was it wasn't good it was a damn
hooker squirt competition it wasn't good
whatever it was yeah i mean there was
somebody real into scat play or
something that's all i'm saying
stimulation i mean i've seen
it was worse than that
i mean i've seen some of the mattresses
on there that i said now somebody legit
got murdered on that [ __ ]
but this one looked like yeah on that
program those are all hooker hotels
hooker motors well yeah it's not fun if
they went to like a nice hotel that was
clean
i mean the whole point is they're
supposed to go and like find you know
dirty panties and like drug
paraphernalia
and and blood stains all over the
mattresses that's part of the fun look
do not go to those [ __ ] hotels
do not go to those [ __ ] things i mean
unless you want everything you can
you're gonna bring back like [ __ ]
what are those little [ __ ] things
once you get your house your [ __ ] bed
bugs
yeah that's what they're pretty careful
about that dead bug
yeah [ __ ] i mean no i mean they they
are aware of depends yeah they always
check all the mattresses and stuff for
bed bed bug poop and [ __ ] like that oh
no those guys do but yeah that's what
that's what i said yeah but i'm saying
no you can go to some of those little
[ __ ] flea bitten [ __ ] hooker
hotels and they got [ __ ] bed bugs in
there and just going in there man you'll
get those in your clothes and you'll
[ __ ] bring them back and then you got
to be honest you can't get rid of it
once they're in there man it's hard to
get rid of those things it pretty much
yeah you pretty much gotta be you gotta
burn your whole house down luckily i
never got them do you know who had those
[ __ ]
[ __ ] my friend tanya that [ __ ]
little chanel [ __ ] girl
fine yeah [ __ ] she had those [ __ ]
bed bugs
couldn't work and it wasn't it wasn't
even in a bed she had a futon and it got
in there somewhere it doesn't have to
they could be in a couch they could be
in anything right or carpet or whatever
this thing keeps hurting me every now
and then and she goes i think something
got me and i [ __ ] that's how the
whole thing started
and i'm looking and i go it looks like a
mosquito bite
because i was laying on the bed there
was something got me like a needle
and i was [ __ ] doing like this you
know and i didn't see anything in there
and i'm looking at it it's just a
totally normal mattress a couple weeks
later she goes that that thing's got bed
bugs she goes i saw a little black
[ __ ] spike come out of the [ __ ]
bed and try to get me
mm-hmm they're alive and they may drink
your blood yeah
she got them from her roommate though
she didn't she didn't go to the hooker
hotel
her roommate had him well that's the
thing you don't have to go to a hooker
hotel even regular hotels have them
sometimes you just got to be really
careful yep you know you had to throw
out everything that's what i'm saying
you pretty much got to burn your house
because you can't get rid of them
they'll go across the floor and they'll
[ __ ] get into the damn couch and then
they're in the couch and waiting for you
and then you say well you spray this and
that man they'll go inside the
electrical out yeah
they're like we don't care we're soccer
fit anywhere
and only one has to survive and they're
laying eggs everywhere then they just
hatch they just keep hatching you can't
get rid of them that's what i mean yeah
they're bugs [ __ ] they've
adapted to that kind of stuff
zach says how did it happened to where
bloody handprints got on the ceiling and
semen stains got behind the toilet yeah
right it's just it's a mystery it's a
mystery like every single one of them
that's your people man that's what
people say
you know you know how that freaky gay
people are man you never can't tell what
they one of the grossest things like
what am toilet one of the grossest
things that i saw on there and i don't
know zack how many times have you tried
to get behind a toilet
come on be honest
one of the grossest things that i saw on
there like there's a pretty gross [ __ ]
on there not gonna lie one of the
grossest things i saw in there was
somebody that like smeared a big huge
booger on the wall yeah yeah that's what
i'm saying i don't even want to talk
about it anymore because i'll probably
like i kind of want to gag but um
explain how many times you got behind a
toilet yeah yeah they can do it you have
to
maybe a bed bug can fit behind you so
people can get behind the toilet
and they fit in there like that they
flatten themselves out like a cockroach
that's what i heard man
i'm gonna have i'm gonna have zach clear
that up
i'm gonna have zach clear it up for you
okay good i i'm sorry
i gave him i gave him all kinds of rope
let's see if he hangs himself he comes
out [ __ ] might make a last suit and
then tell him
all right so anyway
uh yeah so oh uh
skid marks that's what distracted us
yeah yeah
go skid parts get you every time
that's what i'm saying
like i said go somewhere shoes and
presumably they don't wear underwear
either so they shouldn't have either
kind of skid marks uh now that we're
never talking about it yeah so uh
because of the skin marks uh richard the
paranormal investigator guy he's
basically like okay well uh this ghost
teenage girl that's here the one that
committed suicide we kind of want to
like help her cross over or whatever
maybe that'll solve some of the problems
so then he says well i have to find a
medium to do that because i guess he has
to like contract the [ __ ] out because
he's not authorized to send ghosts over
to uh the next dimension or whatever the
[ __ ] so he calls up a medium that he
knows
so the medium comes over and she goes
they said she kind of goes into a trance
and starts talking to
the ghost girl they said it sounded like
she was having a conversation with
somebody like a one-sided conversation
but then the medium says oh there's like
a negative entity that just came in here
and tried to get the girl to stay in the
house like you can't go to the next
dimension and then i wrote on my notes
ghost fight
like with a bunch of
so i guess like the ghosts are fighting
like the guy doesn't want her to leave
and uh apparently she kind of maybe does
want to leave i don't really know okay
zach came back and says oh yeah we were
looking for the condiment
i just sat down the other day take a
dump [ __ ] look around saw some eyes
[ __ ] popping out so what you doing
back there i'll wait for you to sit down
that's all yeah yeah yeah
yeah so get back and every time in a
minute all right yeah
jake says maybe the ghost has ghost
worms and is dragging their ghost butt
on the floor
sorry that was like a really funny i
just pictured casper doing that
which like that's that's pretty funny
all right
so uh so the medium starts yelling at
the male ghost
and tries to get them both to cross over
she's like look [ __ ] you're not
supposed to be here like this is earth
and we don't do ghost [ __ ] here so you
gotta like go to heaven or wherever the
[ __ ]
now at this point and this is a little
anticlimactic i felt
uh apparently the girl ghost the one
that had committed suicide in the house
whose mom was a hoe and all that
business
um apparently she went like she went
whoa she like went off to whatever smell
of sanctity yeah right like the you know
the roses and everything
they didn't say that but you know what i
mean uh but
but so she yeah was she went over there
[ __ ] ed's like where are you going
come back
i could use another teenage girl yeah
right yeah yeah it's like i don't care
if you're dead get your ass back here
yeah pretty much yeah
well that's kind of like what this
[ __ ] ghost was like too it's like you
know what i mean so the girl goes she's
like [ __ ] that i'm out of here
and uh but the man wants to stay there
apparently because he's like no i like
like uh haunting you people because i'm
just the douche in that way so uh then
the medium also says oh there are other
ghosts in here too like you know what i
mean it can't just be the one or the two
it's always kind of like a [ __ ] ton i
kind of feel like that happened too like
with the warrens that come to your house
it can't just be like one damage like oh
it's all you got so many [ __ ] demons
in here we had an army of demons
[Laughter]
well because if it's just one and then
you get rid of it then it's over you
gotta leave yeah that's there goes your
cash cow you've got a couple more
chapters to write exactly so you really
gotta like bulk it up yeah you got a
whole bunch of ghosts in here
but yeah so she says the guy's staying
the teenage girl left but there are a
bunch of other ones in here conveniently
now kelly at this point like i said
she's pregnant and she's like look all
this paranormal this is very very
stressful um and can we move
and uh al
basically is like no man no this is like
so cool and he's just like really
curious and she said he got like super
obsessed with
finding out about the ghost like
researching the ghost and doing all this
other kind of stuff and like she even
said on the show i don't know if they're
still together but she even said on the
show she's like i kind of got the
feeling that he cared more about like
finding out about the ghost than about
like me and our baby that was gonna be
born like that we are we're actually
kind of more in like maybe in danger um
you know and he was just like no it's
cool like you know it's it'll be fine
it's just a ghost blah blah they can't
do anything so yeah she's like okay
jesus christ i guess we have to stay
then because he doesn't want to go
so then they bring in this other guy
this is the third guy right john the
clairvoyant it was he yeah because the
medium was like a little old lady so
this is another dude who's a clairvoyant
so they're just having all the the whole
panel please they didn't call a priest
though
i i know
that's kind of this is the second
episode we've done where
they didn't call priests i kind of feel
like they're earlier
their earlier yeah well the earlier
seasons uh i they didn't call a priest
sometimes don't be [ __ ] when them
priest lets you catholic all right and
even they won't come
okay
there's like no yeah because if you go
to a baptist ministers or anything
they're gonna go know you know i don't
know call the catholics they know all
about that then the catholics won't come
well now they have said that on a few of
the shows it's like people that didn't
belong to a per specific church but were
just like calling around because they
were desperate yeah it's like yeah we
called like pretty much every
denomination everybody's like no we're
not we're not helping you [ __ ] off so
i'm like yeah there's that charity for
you but uh yeah
so this one they just basically stuck
with paranormal investigators so you
know who would come no who
[ __ ] scientologists no they're
muslims
all you got to do is [ __ ] you call a
mosque you tell them that there's a gin
in your house
there'll be [ __ ] thousands of them
down there how come they never do that i
mean for the shows that's because they
don't know any better okay they don't
know they've never been to the middle
east
they don't know any muslims i don't
think i've seen a single episode when i
was in egypt okay every time i'd run
that's actually a good idea you have to
go down to dahab or [ __ ] you know
charming shake or something and you
start hanging out with arabs to speak
english
you could just start asking about
[ __ ] jinns and or tell them about
poultry guys stories you know in the
context they love [ __ ] gin stories
poultry guys stories j ghost stories
islam is all about that [ __ ] we love all
that [ __ ]
that's all codified in in into islam
into islam okay
so just
call the damn mosque and go i think
there's a gin in this house
they'll be over there in a heartbeat
yeah we'll come and get that out yeah
yeah
that's a like i said that's a good pro
tip and like i don't think i don't think
i've seen a single family on any episode
of this like oh no it'd be like think of
that they'll be down there damn video
cameras and all kinds of [ __ ]
where is it where is oh it's gonna be a
gin in here today yeah they're gonna try
to find it
they love that [ __ ]
jake says houses are like crack dens for
ghosts there's never just one chilling
out it's always like 12 and none of them
want to leave right that's pretty much
exactly
so john the clairvoyant comes now he was
interviewed on the show like for real
right because he was talking about he's
one of those uh pendulum having
[ __ ] like pendulum using
[ __ ] where
you know he has this big long yeah it's
a pendulum thing like a silver thing
like on a chain and they're like and
then we hold it over like the ouija
board [ __ ] or whatever and then like you
know this way for yes and this way for
now and [ __ ] like that i'm like yeah
whichever way your [ __ ] hand moves
but yeah so he uses a pendulum now he
says what he discovers and this i
alluded to this earlier
but that the the [ __ ] ghost is
keeping all the other ghosts there like
they start talking to one ghost on the
thing but then it kind of stops talking
like the pendulum just goes boop and
like stops moving so he's like okay well
there's one uh [ __ ] ghost here and
he's like making all the other ones be
quiet because he's like telling them all
to shut up so
like i don't know what like a ghost
could do with another ghost to go they
can't beat each other up or nothing like
that i don't know i'm just so i'm so
curious
so
so yeah
a couple nights after that uh john comes
back to uh do some of the pendulum
action
and wants to like record some evp [ __ ]
so apparently they get some evps
that are again very clear at least what
they showed on the and the people said
that they were very clear too like you
could tell that it was several voices
and like you could tell exactly what
they're saying and one of the voices was
a female voice uh they said he's coming
it's edward so edward is the name of the
[ __ ] ghost spoiler alert
um and then like after that there was a
angry like male voice that said
something like you didn't give him my
name did you
um because i guess that's bad like you
can't tell other like you can't tell
living people what your ghost name is
because then they can i don't know
exercise you or whatever
so at this point
richard the first paranormal
investigator guy
he starts researching the house which i
kind of feel like they probably should
have done earlier but whatever
and he says that part of the house i
kind of got the feeling that this house
was like
maybe had once been like one big mansion
or one big estate that had since been
like portioned out like into apartments
or duplexes or something like that like
they didn't show it like that but that's
kind of like the impression i got the
way they were talking about it
so he said that this particular house
where they were living
back in the 30s and 40s
that this had been the servant's
quarters for like a larger mansion
elsewhere that was either still there
and have been portioned off into
apartments or been torn down i don't
really know but they said this house was
where the servants lived
and edward was the guy who managed the
house during world war ii
and i wrote was a massive douche
because he was just they said he was one
of those [ __ ] that just like
uh you know he's real grabby with the
women and he was just like everyone's my
way or the highway like smacking
everybody around and [ __ ] like that he
was one of those uh you know drunk with
power [ __ ]
so yeah so he just like treated
everybody like [ __ ] and everybody hated
his guts
so
that's who the they're
leading you to assume that that's who
the [ __ ] ghost is
so now kelly is alone in the house again
one night this is happening a lot
she's in the bathroom uh you know
brushing her hair or whatever and the
doorknob starts turning by itself
like
even though it's locked apparently and
then the door like flies open by itself
like that like she doesn't see anything
at this point but the door flies in by
itself apparently it kind of reminded me
of something that happened in
mammoth me and lois in red room one of
those rooms one of the times the door
was shut we were looking at that
doorknob from the inside we were
thinking that it might have been slowly
turning but it's hard to tell it was
perfectly round
yeah you know what i mean oh one of
those kind of like round roll rounds
totally round yeah and it was all
geometrical so if it was turning you
weren't quite sure we're like is that
moving i remember we were looking at it
we were like
that might be moving it looked like it
was
it's hard to say though
it was weird
the knobs underneath the television that
controlled the tint and everything we're
doing that too it looks like they were
moving slightly and you can see the
colors changing on the damn [ __ ]
screen that was weird too
yeah
like the tint and the color and the
[ __ ] contrast knobs
they were just round semicircles poking
out through the bottom and they had a
little fine teeth in them and it looked
like those little teeth were moving but
you could definitely see the distortion
on the screen it's weird
what's happening while we were trying to
watch television
ghosts didn't want to watch what you
guys were watching yeah like [ __ ] this
change i'm gonna [ __ ] it up i had to
walk off from it i was like i don't want
to look at that anymore
well hello there julianne pope i found
this podcast looking for cute cat videos
and somehow came across the pookie
videos oh man i forgot i forgot to put
up like pokey videos this week well the
thing about it is like by like when i
get up
and i'm like oh i should do some film of
her but then like usually by the time i
get ready to like film her she's like
[ __ ] you i'm sleeping you also said that
she you you didn't finish what she said
well yeah that i know i was like i was
saying uh the pookie videos and
discovered that you did recaps of
haunting which i love oh yeah we just
recently started because we when we
first started the show like back in 2016
or whatever uh we did a lot of episodes
about uh you know about a haunting like
we were talking about the episodes but
then we kind of got away from doing it
as we went off in a million other
directions and did a million other
things so like a few weeks ago we
decided hey let's start doing that again
so i got a new show so we just started
doing like live streaming again on
monday so we always watch one on sunday
night and then we talk about it on
monday
so uh you know and kind of [ __ ] around
sometimes sometimes uh we talk about if
i can find anything about the real
actual case and we kind of compare and
contrast this case in particular which
is darkness follows um they didn't use
their real names and they were in shadow
the whole time so i couldn't really find
anything like on
the real case if it really happened but
we're just kind of like clowning on on
the show and outside the show too and
outside the show you know what i mean
just having fun with it yeah there's no
way of knowing you just gotta that's
what i'm saying he's got to roll with
this one because there's not enough
there's not enough to go on
frog said the ghosts wanted to watch a
haunting yeah
that's why they were [ __ ] with the tv
yeah it's like i want to watch oh it was
long before i want to watch paranormal
witness turn it over that was long
before that i want to watch what's the
one with [ __ ] zack baggins on it
ghost hunters yeah he does ghost hunters
right i don't know i don't wanna they
only know the [ __ ] two for the most
part
we gotta get and uh see if we can buy
the the newer seasons of haunting the
ones we don't like i said some of them i
think are available on uh tubey or pluto
yeah we'll have to check it out and see
if there's anything new but we'll see if
there's anything on there i haven't
really checked because like i said we
have like the first seven seasons on
yeah dvd so there's plenty of material
but i wouldn't mind seeing new ones and
see what they're yeah i kind of want to
see the new ones too yeah
uh so yeah so at this point i think i
mentioned this earlier but kelly said
that al seemed obsessed with wanting to
find out what's going on in the house
like about the ghost and all she wanted
to do was get the [ __ ] out because it
was like really scary you know she had
another little daughter she had a baby
on the way and she's like hey this [ __ ]
is like not funny anymore like let's get
out of here but he didn't want to
now
another thing that al started doing was
that every time he heard a weird noise
like footsteps or voices or something he
would like start taking pictures like
wherever the sound seemed to be coming
from
and they showed the pictures to the
paranormal investigator guy and [ __ ]
like that and he said that this one
there were two pictures i think that
were like um [ __ ] up looking and he
said that they had like faces in them
and he said they were very very clear
faces we said they were baby faces right
baby faces and he said there was like
infants like yeah well baby infants
there's newborns and [ __ ] yeah and um
andy said there was like a lot of blood
and stuff uh i believe some of someone
used the phrase spiritual orphanage i
wrote it down on there so that's maybe i
think the paranormal investigator guy
said that
so then later on haley who is kelly's
daughter who like i said she was maybe
she was five or six maybe
so she goes down one night to get a
drink out the kitchen
and while she's down there apparently
she sees an apparition like she sees a
dude like walking past the [ __ ]
doorway now she thinks it's al at first
but it wasn't out like she but she
freaks out like runs back up to the room
and she's like i just saw a dude
downstairs and i was like well hey it
wasn't me she's like i thought it was
you and it's like holy [ __ ] it's a ghost
now the next morning kelly's vacuuming
uh in the upstairs hallway
and the ghost because he's a douche uh
unplugs the vacuum cleaner like you know
it comes unplugged by itself
and then she turns around and sees the
ghost like the dude like at the end of
the hall so she said she actually saw
the apparition like standing in the hall
so she's wigging out she goes in her
bedroom and like locks herself in and
then she calls al and says hey i just
saw the [ __ ] uh come home right now
and so basically at this point she's
like really mad because she's like look
i just want to move out i don't want to
be here anymore i'm seeing the dude now
and i don't like it and uh al's just
like but but but we have to stay it's
like so cool yadda yadda and he's like
okay well i tell you what we'll stay but
we'll only do research
outside of the house which i'm like i'm
not sure if that's gonna help but okay
um
that's kind of the thing because
i don't know i kind of feel like he was
she got really upset because it's like
that's it seemed she said it seemed like
that's all he wanted to talk about too
it's just like hey i went down to the
research and i found like about all this
other stuff about this dude that got
killed at this house and she's like will
you [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up about that
she's like is it bad enough that i have
to be here all the time with this
[ __ ] ghost creeping around like
unplugging my vacuum cleaner and whatnot
i hate it when that [ __ ] happens
it's got what to do
jesus christ so so yeah so she was just
seemed like she was getting mad and he
was just kind of like okay well whatever
but we'll only do like research like
outside the house um you know we won't
like set up cameras and [ __ ] in here
anymore because it's upsetting her
please do us a favor and hit that like
button people that would help us out it
really does work a lot super chats are
active if y'all want to pay jenny and
give her a tip for today's work we very
much appreciate that we got to pay bills
up in this [ __ ] spent three
thousand dollars on a ride on a lawn
mower and i still haven't ramped it over
the pool yet
still haven't done it i will eventually
go
once i get the pool built yeah i was
gonna say you gotta build the pool i'm
gonna build a pool and then i'll ramp
and then i'll ramp the right a lot more
i'm gonna wrap it over the pool with the
jack daniels in my hand okay
a whole bottle on video no just a
[ __ ] glass it'd be funnier if it was
like the whole thing yeah yeah okay i'm
just i'm going for the optics okay so
so uh so yeah
then he finds out and this is what gave
me the idea that maybe this whole the
house was like part of like a larger
house that had been portioned out
because he said al says that he finds
out
that um that there was a guy who lived
in an apartment next door which was kind
of maybe part of the same building i'm
led to believe
that um had maybe seen some [ __ ] too
like had also seen the apparition
and had moved out after part of his
floor collapsed so apparently like the
next door person so the ghost is like
popping all over like the [ __ ] place
like oh the next door neighbors and all
this other kind of stuff
so they decide what ghost has a large
area of effect sure it's been reported
before
this is uh well they probably get bored
in one area so far this little change of
scenery this so far this is fit fitting
in what would be described as a haunting
okay
apparitions
audio a phenomenon
feelings of being watched cold spots
so far nothing's moved yet but that's
minor movement can can still be
haunting but so far mine are haunting
not real powerful we'll see let's keep
going
although like i said if the [ __ ]
happened the way that they said it did
which i kind of doubt um
then they got like some of the clearest
uh evps and ghost photos they did not
show that but they did not show them so
i'm kind of
skeptical i'm skeptical where is the
evidence that's what i'm saying if it
was that good then they would have
showed it on the show like look go
sensei every now and then they will show
a real piece of evidence on the haunting
but mostly they fake the evidence so
they say and the photos and then they
show a picture of a doctored photo
because the real photo isn't impressive
enough
the series that'll show you the real
evidence would be paranoid
that'll show you what they have and
they're usually not that good
[Laughter]
which is why haunting doesn't do it yeah
it's not that they're not that good it's
just that they're not it's not
conclusive that's what i mean it doesn't
improve particles
no particle of dust in the flesh yeah
like 99 of them are just like orbs i'm
like yeah that's like a dust or that's a
particle come on or it's like a bug
flying in front of the camera yeah i've
seen that i've had and then uh [ __ ]
amorphous form no cigarette smoke from
the cigarette in your hand when you take
a picture and you you also have to thank
you block frog i've got a haunting
season eight and nine if you'd like
copies i could send them ooh that'd be
awesome actually uh
dude i think we no we just have one
through seven one through seven
he's got eight and nine well hold on one
sec there because if if he does
um
i wouldn't mind buying that physical
medium you know what i mean because you
know i don't really like the [ __ ]
copy i like to have the real thing i
don't but the last i checked and this
was years back those weren't available
on dvd if they're available they might
be now i'll buy them i mean it was a
long time ago yeah so just drop in the
comments section if that's available on
dvd i'll just buy them
but yeah thank you very much thank you
very much
um
jake says bit of aside i'm looking at
that awesome poster of nosferatu in the
background love how it's lit thank you i
love that yesterday that's like one
right it's actually lit darker in real
life than it looks on the screen but can
you imagine your house being haunted by
klaus kinski i'd have to move
there's a perv man that's what i mean
with my luck it's every time i got
haunted you'd be like a [ __ ]
perverted incest mother incestuous pedo
[ __ ] yeah he's creepy as [ __ ]
zack says he's your daughter alone you
go yeah yeah i mean shouldn't have to be
said but yeah leave your [ __ ]
daughter alone zack said you guys should
go stay at a haunted hotel and do a live
stream we i you know what i've thought
about doing that because we've been
asked to do that a couple times like to
go stay at like a haunted location and
like if i was gonna
it's like it'd be cool if we could do
because you know we did a whole show
there's like a bunch of haunted places
in like st augustine and stuff like that
which is only like an hour from here but
you know it might be cool to do
something like that i know if i get back
to that get back to mammoth i know just
psychologically this [ __ ] would kick off
if anybody wants to finance that trip
just me you
me you jen and maybe another witness or
something and you want to pay for it
i got lois is still alive she'll
remember exactly where that [ __ ]
because she was older than i was at the
time she'll remember does anybody own it
now
no the last i heard was for sale we
checked a couple years back it was for
sale and i was looking at the internet i
mean i don't know if anybody's bought it
at this point we found it on zillow like
a one like a year or two ago but
somebody might have bought it no one's
ever lived in that it was always bought
and sold by companies or
individuals it's like a time well not
like a time share but
it was just when you stayed there like a
cup the company owned it and then they
let people like employees like stay
there for like a week at a time
vacation yeah it was it was owned by
conoco oil
that's who owned it and they gave it out
to executives for use as like a reward
and my mom got it got dibs on it but she
didn't want to go so she let her sister
go and i went with her
and that's what happened it was for the
christmas season
and she was like you'll be away for
christmas but you have fun down there
you don't have to go you say oh no i
want to go there for christmas they went
there for christmas i'm not sure we
actually had a christmas ceremony though
it might have been a little bit before
christmas or maybe it was christmas
but i don't remember i think yeah it was
christmas winner
and [ __ ] um
because i don't think we did the gift
[ __ ] i think we did all that before we
went like opening presents and stuff
kind of like christmas that already
happened that year
yeah this [ __ ] it was it was bizarre
but uh i know that i can get ramped up
and have that [ __ ] happen again because
it'll event it happens
here every now and then but it it takes
about a month for it to start firing up
but over there especially if [ __ ]
lois was with me
too bad red's dead if red was with me
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] would kick off quick
me red
wesley
and lois
it'd go back to the way it was i think
it started doing it start moving stuff
throwing things it was [ __ ] weird man
black frog said about uh seasons eight
and nine it said i downloaded them i
don't blame you physical media is way
better yeah uh get pookie a snack with
the tip okay we will we'll we'll get her
yeah they were available we'll get her
some more meat sticks that's right they
were available
i don't know if
i know that they were available for
download but i don't
know if they ever sold them as a package
because i'd like a package
to go along i don't think they do
anymore
yeah it's not as good a series as it
used to be well there's not the demand i
guess for it
like i said the first four seasons were
in a box set because i bought you that
and the i think five six and seven i
bought individually
but yeah and i think the whole season on
one disk yeah after that they didn't
like sell them anymore right so okay so
they go into they said they go into the
basement i don't think this was the
basement of the house they were staying
in but i think it was another
part of the house that had been
portioned off into another house but
that was the same owner you know what i
mean i was led to believe that this is
where the guy who had seen
the apparition of the dude and then had
moved out like in this other apartment i
was
of the impression that this was that
guy's apartment and because al went to
the owner and like talked to him and
nobody was living in there he said okay
why don't you go in there and like see
what you can see
so they go over there i think i don't
know if that's correct or not
but so they're in the basement and they
make like this little ouija board and
the dude's got his pendulum or whatever
now what he said it's on amazon prime
but i guess he meant that you can buy
dvds on amazon prime i think that's what
he's talking about
he can clarify
well no i mean amazon prime if that
means you can rent it i imagine
yeah or amazon prime also sells dvds
though
well yeah but i mean if you're talking
about buying dvds you would just say
it's you can buy it on amazon you
wouldn't say amazon prime okay amazon
prime that's usually i mean i assume i
assume they're talking like prime video
like that you like rent it all right
so so they're doing the ouija board and
apparently a 19 year old girl named
angela answers them
she says that she died in 1943
and when they asked her how she died uh
she spelled out they said she spelled
that bleed
and then spelled out my baby so you know
abortion uh so she says about a doctor
uh that was called the butcher
now
al goes and finds like a history
professor like in the area and she said
oh yeah there was a guy who was like an
abortionist then this was back when uh
abortion was you know illegal and so uh
that a very famous abortionist had lived
in the house he fled the us in the 40s
but edward the [ __ ] ghost from the
others that everybody's been seeing
um
like worked with him or took over his
practice or something like that i was
not real clear on that
so they find out all that stuff um and
al very wisely chooses not to tell his
wife about it
um but she's kind of like um they're in
the bedroom
al and kelly are in the bedroom and a
crucifix flies off the nightstand and
breaks in the bedroom while al is kind
of telling kelly about some of the ghost
[ __ ] that's one of the few times that
something moved
yeah i think there was only two times so
the crucifix flies off and breaks
um
you know and kelly's just like [ __ ] this
like can we please get the [ __ ] out of
here
at this point al like confronts the
ghost like hey come out and face me blah
blah like trying to be a man and all
that but uh nothing happens
now at this point kelly goes into labor
and uh she has a little girl who they
said was named charity but i'm sure
that's not the kid's real name
now the guys go down to the basement and
use the ouija board to talk to angela
again and they ask her well you know she
said i guess she's assuming like you
know that she got murdered and they're
like where is your body
now
the pendulum guy says at this point when
they asked the pendulum stood straight
out i'm assuming they mean horizontally
which would indeed be quite something if
that really did happen yeah um he said
it stood straight out like i'm assuming
like pointing toward where the body was
he said some funny [ __ ]
what did he say he said that thing would
fly around and it got to the point where
i had to hold on to it or it would fly
out you always got to hold on to a damn
pension well yeah otherwise it'll just
go yeah it'll fall on the ground
and hold on to it
yeah i'd have to hold on to it too
[Laughter]
he's got to hold it and say yeah you got
to hold it yeah you got to hold it yeah
so uh so yeah so apparently the
pendulums stand straight out so they're
like okay well maybe that's where the
body is
so uh so apparently what happened and
i'm guessing they determined this from
talking to angela on the ouija board
thing it wasn't even they didn't even
have a real ouija board they just like
put they wrote letters on a bunch of
scraps of paper and put them in like a
you know a semi-circle and then they had
the pendulum like kind of swinging which
like i said that seems
pretty ripe for uh shenanigans but you
know what i mean
so uh so she says apparently that edward
uh and the doctor uh [ __ ] the abortion
up
and they were like well she looks like
she's pretty much dying but she's not
quite dead yet so they dug a hole in the
cellar
and we're gonna i thought they were
gonna bury her alive and i'm just like
jesus christ that's [ __ ] cold-blooded
um but at least they had the decency to
like throw rocks on top of her to kill
her first before they buried her so you
know that was nice well they kind of
didn't say that in the movie no i'm just
saying i'm just i'm i'm looking forward
to him throwing rocks on her and then
[ __ ] the the investors
yeah they threw rocks on her to make
sure she was dead didn't necessarily
mean that she was alive
but they kind of made it seem like they
killed her yeah well because the actress
was like laying there kind of like uh
like she was clearly still alive this
this goes back to
a haunting that's what i mean we don't
know liberties a lot
with imagery
i mean their their whole job is to make
a good episode yeah they're not really
worried about like if it's not worried
about actually that's your reality or
not and this is a good episode it is
yeah it's an interesting case
but i also
know based on the haunting we're not
getting everything they're just telling
us what they want us to know they're
just telling you the good [ __ ] yeah
scary [ __ ]
and like i said probably exaggerating
they're probably leaving stuff out too
yeah well they and we talked about this
on the last show where yeah
i think they leave stuff out um if it's
not like in service to their narrative
because they're trying to make it like
you said they're trying to make it an
entertaining show so they're trying to
make it more like a movie like a
three-act structure type thing when you
know in real life it probably doesn't
like things don't happen like that like
haunting a summer win was mystifying to
me i loved that case
until i eventually tracked down what
summer when actually looked like
and explained a lot summer wind was a
[ __ ] dump you know what i mean that's
why people didn't want to work on it
it wasn't worth anything yeah
but yeah so we don't know if she was
actually dead when they buried her or we
don't know
um so they're like okay well
he asked the owner apparently they're
like well hey can we dig out the floor
in the basement there
and the owner is just kind of like sure
i was gonna replace the floor anyway
so have at it
so they go i don't know if they told him
like why they were digging the floor out
hey we're looking for a body but so yeah
so they start digging the floor out
and they said that all they found the
first day was a flagstone uh like the
ones that were used to make the
fireplace so they're like oh maybe this
is one of the stones that was dropped on
the girl you know what i mean but oh
gosh it's the end of the day and we're
all tired we can't finish the digging
job this evening
and then conveniently the next day they
come back
and the owner has brought in a crew
to pour new concrete
in the floor and i was like again that
seems a little convenient yeah because
you would think that look if you're
looking for a body
i would think that you would tell the
owner hey we're looking for a body
um you know give us a couple days at
least like to come up with some [ __ ]
whereas you know the owner's just like
no it's like whoa thanks for tearing out
the floor i just came in and they've
already poured concrete bye
the way i interpreted it is that the
owner [ __ ] was afraid that a body was
really there and he's just like well
yeah it could have been that too yeah no
i don't want to get involved in that
[ __ ] right yeah because then they'll be
in here for [ __ ] months right so i
think that's how i interpreted the story
which there could be something yeah
because then well yeah because then he's
like well man i don't want my house to
be a crime scene right some [ __ ] back to
the 19th
and that man [ __ ] that [ __ ] uh so that
could go either way it could have been
that i mean if it did happen like that
yeah that that makes a lot more sense
than like them just coincidentally like
what kind of didn't make sense about
that part of it is that they dig down
they find the flagstones and they say
we gotta go get some heavier equipment
tomorrow to do the to take pick these
flag stones up they didn't dig that far
flagstones don't weigh much that's what
i mean it's like bmw
just fry the [ __ ] out with a crowbar
strong enough to jerky dick you're not
strong enough to [ __ ] jerk out that
[ __ ] piece of stone
i mean they were probably just like yeah
they were just like flat like 15 pound
stones what do you think it's like i
could move that [ __ ] come on yeah
come on don't be a weirdo
you're looking for a body tell them
you're looking for a body tell them zack
tell them what a real man could do and
apparently they were like oh they felt
really bad because they were like well
we wanted to you know send her to her
like we wanted to find her body and blah
blah yeah so yeah i was like okay but
like you said it could have just been
that the owner was like yeah what if
they really do find a body yeah
like i said then it's going to be a
crime scene and then i can't rent it out
and then i'm out of my right and then i
don't want everybody's going to
that's that's how i interpreted it so
yeah
get them guys in here quick no we're not
we're not doing this we're not doing
this we're done with that we're done no
we're just like back yep we don't care
thank you for turning my floor [ __ ] out
of here yeah that's probably what it was
uh so yeah so the last thing that
happened
was kelly was upstairs and she was
getting ready to give the new baby a
bath
and then um
meanwhile richard the paranormal
investigator guy
he has like some spidey sense type stuff
that happens that he senses that the
ghost is mad because they've been
looking for angela's body
and will take revenge on the baby like
the living baby
uh that kelly just had uh so he's like
oh [ __ ] like your baby's in danger
and apparently at the same time that
this happened like kelly is in the room
and a bottle it didn't look like i mean
in the show it just looked like one of
like a one of those johnson and johnson
baby shampoo bottles i think it kind of
looked like that it wasn't a glass
bottle or nothing it just looked like a
plastic bottle so this bottle like comes
[ __ ] flying across the room
and almost hits the baby
uh and kelly at this point is just she
is no longer having it and she says to
al like he comes up here and she's like
that [ __ ] bottle just flew across the
room and almost hit the baby she's like
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're coming or
not i don't you know i'm done with this
ghost [ __ ] and i'm just leaving without
you uh you know unless you want to come
with me so then finally finally he's
like okay fine we'll move and she's like
jesus christ at last um but they
interviewed him at the end he said um
you know if somebody told me like that i
could still go back there and like dig
up that floor and see if that body was
there i absolutely would so he's
obviously still
obsessed with or was as of when this
show came out which was
when was the first season 2005
2005 2006 something like that oh my god
so yeah so i don't know dominion
pitchers new dominion i think is what it
was called that was the company that
owned it yeah well the the
logo that you see at the beginning is
called like timeline media or something
like that
name like new dominion makes you think
it was uh some kind of a christian
company it sounds christian it sounds
christian it sounds christian and a lot
of the stuff was christian-y kinda
but i think like this this was season
one yeah and i don't think it was the
same i mean i could totally be wrong i'd
have to like look through the the
production history of this but it seemed
like the earlier episodes were not as
religious-y like sometimes if the family
was religious they'd be like yeah we
called the priest and stuff like that
but there was a bunch of episodes where
it wasn't really
like religion wasn't really like brought
into it it started with new dominion i
think they were really i think it's
christian
i think it is i do but i think they were
tried to stay close i think they were
close stayed with the story
it did have
i'm not saying that's a bad thing that's
great it's just
maybe it's just the name
but then later on it did seem to be more
churchy but it didn't seem to go into
more so maybe that was just my
perception but i just kind of feel i
kind of feel like the original ones
weren't as churchy like i felt like when
we were watching the later ones they
felt a little boring every single one
was like a demon and we had to like
bring in and everybody's praying at the
end and [ __ ] like that where it's like
the ones the early ones like sometimes
that happened but not usually like
usually like it was this one where it's
just they were just calling in like a
paranormal investigator and nobody
mentioned anything about anything i
think it was the same company
through the first that you know that
first big stack that we have yeah the
first set i think it's the same company
but uh yeah i think so too you know just
that's just how they did it they were
good stories yeah
black frog said have you two ever heard
of patrick mcnee's ghost stories i have
not it was made in 1997 pretty cool
series i'm gonna write that down though
because that sounds like right up my
alley matter of fact where'd the pen go
oh here i had it yeah black frog says
that they're only available available
digitally on amazon prime
yeah that's what i thought i don't even
think they bother because
there's probably not like a demand
anymore
i mean there's not a demand for
dvds in general as much as they're used
to i'd love to have physical medium
though i know i usually do too not so
much with movies like if it's a movie i
really really like and i know i'm gonna
like watch over and over again then
y'all buy it but i'm more like that with
books i really like to have like the
physical book so i can read it again i
will read ebooks i'm not like a verse
but
i if you know if it's a book i really
like then i usually like to buy it like
i like to have it you know yeah
um all right so
yeah i guess that's about it that was
all that happened on that episode uh and
like i said i couldn't find anything
else about it really because it wasn't
like their real names or nothing like
that but like i said this one seemed a
lot less
it was it was no demonic [ __ ] which was
nice
and it wasn't it wasn't real poltergeist
i'll tell you what you got the list for
the other ones that we have to do um
okay so the other one's ours that was
darkness follows right yeah the other
ones are we're evil lurks yeah
legend trippers
um
fear house okay the presents okay and
okay one one other one all right let's
tell them because some people
complaining that they didn't know which
one it was they would like to watch it
before well let's do fear house
we're going to do fear houses next
monday
so
you guys can watch that one
yeah cause we didn't know either we just
kind of like and after that we'll do
legend trippers that's a [ __ ] uh
request from a subscriber
who actually knows uh somebody who was
involved in that case we'll do fear
house or legend trippers after that
yeah
ramone says wikipedia says new dominion
produced a haunting from the first
season onwards yeah and he said maybe
the writer's production staff of the
later seasons got more churchy maybe
that's what it was like maybe you know
maybe it sold more maybe that's what i
mean like and you know either that or
like they had new writers or they had
like a new manager or whatever the [ __ ]
like they had like a new production team
i don't know in those days i would think
ghost stuff would sell real well to to a
to a religious audience
so you you'd want to move
religious cases with religious aspects
to the forefront
plus it'll it's also kind of like
the exorcist and and evil horror and a
lot of the horror classics
so it gives that vibe you know
where you're not really answering
questions you're just got [ __ ] adding
to mystery
all right yeah because most people watch
these as like a form of horror movie
really that's why i watch them yeah yeah
that's what i watch them for they're
like horror movies that you could kind
of suspend your disbelief because it was
supposedly based on something that
really happened you could pick through
it like maybe maybe some of the [ __ ] did
happen
you know which i'm pretty sure a lot of
this did happen you know i think a lot
of these cases were were based in
something
whether or not they exaggerated yeah
probably and they left stuff out that
was
not in service to the case too because
we could research and find out that
there's more
that there's more details
and the details sometimes demystify a
lot of [ __ ]
a lot of the issues you'd have with
watching the episode
the example i use everybody knows the
haunting summer went
part of the [ __ ] mystery of the
haunting of summer wind is why would
somebody [ __ ] not want to come and
and help
fix this beautiful [ __ ] ancient
mansion
you know [ __ ] the witnesses are like
yeah nobody would come work on the house
like you know they owe a haunted house
oh no we're not going to work on that
house
until you see pictures of what it looked
like back then
it was a dump
so contractors were like oh you don't
put money in that i don't want to be
involved in that you can't rebuild that
that's got to be torn down
you know
that's what was happening
that house should have been condemned
that wood didn't even look treated i'm
like surprised that it wasn't actually
like after i saw photos of it yeah
it looked like a haunted house because
it just wasn't built right
like i said it looked like it was made
of wood it was giant yeah it was made
out of water it was made of untreated or
poorly treated wood yeah it looked like
it looked like it was made of wood that
termites eddie yeah and it was warping
and [ __ ] all the paint was coming off
of it and they were like man that's got
to be demolished you can't just paint
that
they were living in it and we're burning
all the furniture the ghosts are so bad
in there you could burn that whole house
down if you wanted to it wouldn't matter
you know that house was a dump and it
burned down eventually they said well
lightning struck it on the fateful night
no
neighbors the neighbors went down and
burned that [ __ ] down because the kids
are hanging out
i think the neighbors
they still want to say that on the show
but i'm pretty sure that's what happened
neighbors got sick of that [ __ ] burn
that [ __ ] down it's like look at that
eyesore yeah
which is a shame because it probably
looks really cool like back in the old
days back in the 30s it never got taken
care of
yeah david june only just now got maybe
you want to show up now man says hey
people holy [ __ ] we've been on for like
an hour and a half already yeah like i
said we've been on like for [ __ ] uh
twice as long as the actual episode
i think the episodes are what like 45
minutes or 48 minutes or something like
that we're never like stretching this
[ __ ] out
well because we were like making jokes
about it yeah that's part of the fun
it's like if you just wanted to like
watch the episode then just watch the
episode you can sit around listen to
[ __ ] doomsayers and bad news that's
coming about all the bad [ __ ] that's
happening or you could escape from it
over here
talk about ghosts
yeah ghosts and true crime and [ __ ]
yeah i mean true crime is still like
pretty great but you know what i mean
it's still good kind of entertaining i
got two followers on my [ __ ] twitch
channel i was gonna play [ __ ] legend
wow two whole ones got two of them
uh you can find me on twitch
it's tom 13 o'clock no all lower case no
apostrophes tom 13 o'clock on twitch
uh once i get my headset set up i got to
buy a headset so you can hear him
swearing and stuff so i can talk
i'm gonna play uh i'm gonna start
streaming
classic
tomb raider i'm gonna start off with
legend and then we'll do anniversary and
then i'll do
[ __ ] underworld
90s [ __ ] back when laura croft character
was cute run around them long legs
[ __ ] kicking [ __ ] with the guns
[ __ ]
now she just looks like any old woman
she looks like a mortal woman now i
liked when she looked like a damn video
game character
there were big old boobies bouncing she
had big boobs they bounced and long
skinny legs and she was [ __ ] she had
big boobs they bounced
big eyes
and uh she uh was the female james bond
rich girl who
turned her back on that life and went
off to [ __ ] do criminal energy i want
to go do adventures dealing stealing
[ __ ] ancient relics and [ __ ]
killing criminals that were trying to
steal them before her yeah that's good
and then having paranormal experiences
i mean that sounds like the life yeah
yeah yeah the rich girl she could do
whatever they want he had nice toys and
everything she basically like james bond
without the responsibility yeah well
james bond slash indiana jones yes james
bond like with all the best stuff of
both and none of and none of the bad
stuff yeah like you said she didn't have
to work for anybody she could just she
had all the money she had all the money
and she could just be like well [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna go [ __ ] it i'm going to
peru and i'm going to go down an old
tomb and i'm going to [ __ ] fight some
gangsters yeah yeah because that's how
lara croft do yep
but yeah so uh tonight we'll watch a
movie we don't know which one yet
uh that we'll talk about tomorrow okay
we don't know what movie we're gonna do
we never know and uh wednesday the main
show if you didn't what david june
followed me on twitch okay thank you
if uh
if you got real into the ghost [ __ ]
today we're doing even more ghost [ __ ]
on wednesday
haunted bars and pubs okay that was one
other thing somebody recommended it last
week so i put it in the poll and uh that
handily won
so i'm gonna i mean there's so many like
i already started like looking like for
all the research and everything and just
like oh my god i'm gonna like winnow
this down but uh you know i'm trying i'm
gonna try to keep it to like a
reasonable
number
uh but you know there's there's a lot so
i'm gonna try and kind of just pick the
most interesting ones but it'll be a fun
show i feel like uh you know so
i don't know so come by tomorrow um
we'll i don't know what movie we're
going to do but we'll figure it out
maybe got further too i don't know are
we going to watch it tonight
yeah whatever movie we're watching
tonight we gotta talk it can't be a long
movie it's look how late it is
oh yeah [ __ ] okay so maybe we'll have to
pick something shorter yeah that always
happens it's like we did the first
godfather and i'm proud of us yeah but
then i was like well [ __ ] we have to do
two and three because you know we got
sent the the whole trilogy
and but it just seems like every time
like it's we get it's time to like
settle down and watch a movie it's
already so late that i'm like oh man i'm
just gonna fall asleep so sure like if
we try to like watch a two two and a
half hour movie i'm gonna like fall
asleep
what we could do is do a boat we could
do a bonus haunting and watch fear house
and do fear house tomorrow
that's one idea
yeah that might be a better idea because
now i'm gonna have to make a whole new
introduction like a haunting tuesdays
no no just be a bonus one because that's
only 45 minutes that's true you know
what i mean and it's easy that's true
maybe maybe we should just because it
ran like we just did we'll just do for
your house
all right would you would you guys want
to hear from your house tomorrow
yeah maybe we can do that like instead
of another movie right because a movie
is going to be an hour and a half at
least yeah like i said i've been up
since six o'clock working right yeah so
we'll just do that usually by the time 9
30 or 10 rolls around i'm like watching
william shatner i mean like yeah ma'am
we run this [ __ ]
you know where do we need to boss well i
know that but it's like i do like yes
i do like to like take advice from
people like if more people want to see
that then like just see a random movie
that we don't know what it is they're
going sweet yeah do that okay we'll do
for your house though yeah we'll do it
for your house i mean like i said we
have so many episodes we're never gonna
it's nice i'd rather just sit back not
like we're gonna run out it's only 45
minutes and [ __ ] those things are fun
yeah and they're going yeah yeah yeah do
fear all right watch fear house tonight
we're gonna talk about tomorrow all
right all right that'll be good
we're gonna watch it right now watch
that yeah we're gonna watch it uh right
now well in a couple of minutes yeah
well i haven't even finished that one
okay so i'm still good because i was i
was talking like a bunch so i didn't
really put a chance to yeah sure why not
okay and then it'll like water it down
so yeah but yeah so tomorrow okay so
we'll do another haunting episode
tomorrow we'll do fear house so if you
want to watch it and
you know play along or whatever then you
can do that so we will see you guys
again uh tomorrow evening
good night